وثقت هيئه الدفاع عن نصر ابو زيد بيانه في
السفاره المصريه بامستردام
ليقدموه الى النائب العام الذي ارسل
البيان بدوره الى دار الافتاء المصريه
يا اما هو يرجع بعد الاراء المشتبه فيها
يا اما يا اما الطرف الاخر محكمه تقتنع
انه تاويله ممكن يحمل على اوجه صحيح ده
اللي قال انه ما ينفعش الناس همم تتهم
بمثل هذه الجريمه ويحكم علياء من غير
مناقشه مباشره ومفصله وصريحه
وقال كمان راي الامام مالك انه لو في
المعروف انه اي راي ممكن يحمل
99 واجهه على انه كفر ووجه واحد على انه
ايمان
يحمل على الوجه اللي فيه
الايمان يعني كان
مستنير ومتسامح في الفتوه بتاع الازهر همم
لم يبدي رايه لكن في قسم كان يسمون نفسه
علماء الازهر وهؤلاء همم اصدروا بيانات
ادانا وهؤلاء عندهم
ميولوانيه
وظلوا حتى على هذا هذه الاراء حتى قامت 25
ينا